Tesla cars are a game-changing option
for anyone in the market for a stylish
eco-friendly and high performance
vehicle founded in 2003 by the current
Twitter CEO himself Elon Musk Tesla cars
are electric vehicles known for their
Sleek design impressive performance and
advanced technology with their
futuristic technology and imposing
performance Tesla cars are leading the
charge in the transition to sustainable
energy and after relying on four models
for its rapid and meteoric growth Tesla
says it will finally deliver its much
anticipated models in 2023 such as the
Cyber truck pickup the Roadster the
hatchback and even an autonomous Robo
taxi let's take a look at all the
confirmed details including specs
performance and price tags Tesla cyber
truck pickup the Cyber truck looks like
it was beamed down from an alien
spaceship with its scratch and dent
resilient exterior the sleek and sharp
edge design of the Cyber truck is owed
to none other than a 30 times Cold
rolled stainless steel allegedly the
hardest thing Tesla could find coupled
with its ability to tow up to 14 000
pounds this bad boy is tough seriously
tough plagued by numerous delays this
boxy electric pickup was announced in
2019 and production was to commence in
late 2021 but was then delayed till 2022
but now it's been confirmed to be
available to the public in 2023 uh
fingers crossed the interior of the
Cyber truck is something out of the
Matrix movies and in fact Elon Musk has
described the vehicle as if Neo from The
Matrix had a truck he was quite spot on
with that comparison the Cyber truck's
cabin looks just as angular as its
polarizing exterior even the seats have
an atypical geometric design the first
images of the Cyber truck Spartan cabin
show a slab-like Marvel effect dashboard
largely commanded by one large 17-inch
touchscreen and a yoke-shaped steering
wheel the Cyber truck would be able to
house up to six people and its six foot
four cargo bed offers 100 cubic feet of
space enough with the Aesthetics let's
get down to the performance of this
Beast the Cyber truck is available with
not one not two but three electric
motors the three possible configurations
are dependent on the number of Motors
each additional motor means faster
acceleration longer driving range and
greater towing capacity so if you're a
single mom or someone who loves the fast
life there is a perfect configuration
for you while the single motor truck has
rear-wheel drive the Dual and tri-motor
models have all-wheel drive the single
motor will go from 0 to 60 miles an hour
in 6.5 seconds and top out at 110 miles
an hour the dual motor cyber truck will
reach 60 miles an hour in just 4.5
seconds and have a top speed of 120
miles an hour but those looking for the
ultimate performance will appreciate the
tri-motor model which Tesla says will
essentially teleport from 0 to 60 miles
an hour in 2.9 seconds with a top speed
of 130 miles an hour how's that for
performance the pricing of the Cyber
truck pickup will be dependent on the
number of electric motors each has the
single motor is available from a price
of 39 900 the dual motor starts out at
49 900 while the tri-motor can be
purchased at 69 900 for an extra seven
thousand dollars Tesla will offer a full
self-driving option but the self-driving
autopilot feature will still be
available for all models with its
impressive performance and gorgeous
Aesthetics for both an electric vehicle
and a pickup the Cybertron gives Tesla a
potentially strong seller given how well
trucks sell in the USA however it'll
have to compete with the Ford F-150
Lightning the GMC Hummer EV and the
rivion r1t right out the gate Tesla
Roadster the original Tesla Roadster put
the all-electric automaker on the map
even if most Model S and model X buyers
don't remember it now it's back in a
more refurbished and rebranded iteration
the second generation Tesla Roadster
beats its predecessor by adding two
small rear seats significantly more
driving range and a much higher level of
performance it is rumored to be the most
powerful electric vehicle Tesla has ever
produced let's get down to analyzing its
parts performance and price range the
Roadster is a sporty modern and
sophisticated sports car that makes the
most of Tesla's traditional design cues
it will be a two plus two seater
although it's not likely that fully
grown adults can fit into the tiny back
seats you can turn it into a convertible
by storing the removable glass roof in
the trunk just in case you want the wind
smashing against your face at 200 miles
an hour its exterior is smooth and free
of embellishments like other Tesla
models it has a low front hood sharply
angled headlights and a sporty lower
bumper with the side view dominated by
large wheels and must skill offenders
the interior of the Roadster is expected
to retain Tesla's signature minimalist
interior design Tesla's usual white and
black interior will be on the menu with
the dashboard being covered by a suede
of carbon fiber giving it a more sporty
and high-tech feel than luxurious the
dashboard is nothing more than a
horizontal slab with nothing on it
although there is a floating length and
touchscreen display in the center there
is also no traditional gauge cluster and
the steering wheel is the company's
controversial yoke design expected to be
equipped with three electric motors one
in the front and two at the back the
all-wheel drive Tesla Roadster has been
heralded as the fastest car in the world
Tesla claims that the Roadster will go
from 0 to 60 miles an hour in 1.9
seconds 0 to 100 miles an hour in 4.2
seconds and can clear the quarter mile
in a ferocious 8.8 seconds the top speed
will be over 250 miles an hour which
would be quite an achievement for an
electric vehicle Tesla insists it will
offer the base Roadster for two hundred
thousand dollars and a limited edition
Founders series for fifty thousand
dollars more there are no specific
details on what differentiates the two
other than the fact that only one
thousand founder series models will be
built Tesla hatchback the new Tesla
hatchback will Mark the firm's Landmark
shift away from the high-end electric
vehicle sector into more accessible
territory during the 2022 quarter three
Financial Report Elon Musk confirmed
that Tesla started developing a smaller
cheaper electric vehicle that could be
an alternative to the Volkswagen ID3 and
coupra born the Tesla hatchback is
something of a mystery with multiple
supply chain issues and delays to
production so there are a few unknowns
about the vehicle but here is everything
we know about the hatchback so far no
design specs or illustrations of the
Tesla hatchback have been seen that said
a hatchback is a very particular design
so we should expect some sort of
tesla-esque vehicle that looks like a
blend between the Tesla Model Y and
something like a Nissan Leaf or VW ID3
traditional Tesla features will be
available including the company's
infotainment system access to the
supercharger Network and some form of
autopilot feature some big promises
about the hatchback's battery have been
revealed promises that suggest it will
come powered by the new 4680 battery
cells the same cell set to be used in
the Tesla cyber truck and the 2022 model
y these battery cells use a tablesp
design which offers five times the
energy capacity and six times the power
of comparable batteries all while
reducing the cost very little is known
about the hatchback's performance and
range at this point but given the car's
price tag and presumed size it's likely
that it only has a single electric motor
though whether it'll be front or rear
wheel drive is unclear the rear wheel
drive is the most likely candidate as
Tesla is yet to produce a front-wheel
drive car as for range Elon Musk
believes that anything less than 2 250
miles of range is unacceptably low so we
can likely expect a minimum of 250 miles
from the Tesla hatchback Elon Musk has
already confirmed that the new Tesla
hatchback could cost 25 000 that's less
than half the price of the model 3
standard range rear wheel drive which
cost sixty thousand and has 305 miles of
range it's unclear whether that is the
full purchase price or if that includes
the quotes potential savings discount
Tesla advertisers Tesla semi the Tesla
semi is a beast and is the future of
trucking more powerful more efficient
and fully electric the straightforwardly
named semi for semi-truck was announced
in 2017 as Tesla's introduction into the
semi-truck game Elon Musk explained the
reason behind building a semi it's
apparently a response to semi trucks
being responsible for around 20 percent
of emissions despite representing just
one percent of vehicle sales in the US
and that the Mi is being manufactured
with the goal of creating sustainable
energy the semi is capable of taking on
truly heavy loads towing a gross vehicle
weight of 82 000 pounds the maximum
allowed by law which is 2 000 pounds
more than diesel rigs are permitted the
truck's durability and survivability has
also been demonstrated with the
semi-running over objects running
through deep puddles loose dirt roads
and even snow-covered roads to prove its
ready to face multiple driving scenarios
head on Tesla displayed a graph of a 500
Mile test run from Fremont to San Diego
with the semi-hauling just under its 80
000 pound capacity as a fully production
version at no point during that full 500
mile run did the Tesla Semi Stop for
charging though there was one break for
the driver to use the bathroom and take
the required break period for commercial
truck drivers the drive system of the
semi is a triple motor setup this means
it comes with three independent Motors
providing instant torque and unmanned
match power at any speed so drivers can
merge safely and keep Pace with traffic
able to accelerate from 0 to 60 miles an
hour in 20 seconds the semi also
maintains Highway level speeds even up
steep terrains the Tesla semi is more
than just the electronics it is also
very driver-centric the interior is
built around the driver and not simply
because of its Central seating position
it features your typical wireless
charging and a USBC port for mobile
devices along with convenient areas to
keep those devices the standard Tesla
semi is also bigger than any day cab
truck which can be surprisingly
uncomfortable if you've never been
inside one anyone over six feet tall
will be more than comfortable it also
includes features aiding productivity
like a one button rear dump to help with
loading trailers along with built-in
safety checks that the driver can
operate within the cab and help meet
safety checks while on their Drive
unlike Tesla's latest passenger vehicles
the semi has a round steering wheel but
does use the tip Tesla wheel touch
controls and scroll wheel it also
features two touchscreen monitors to
allow for multiple views so the driver
can monitor the load check blind spots
and use guidance without having to swap
views on a single screen rather than a
portrait layout in the s or X both
screens are in landscape layout with the
steering wheel in between Tesla
semi-pricing starts at a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and goes all the
way to two hundred thousand dollars for
the 500 Mile version 2023 is going to be
the year of Tesla with a wide range of
insane electrical Vehicles being
released ranging from semi trucks to low
end affordable cars to high-tech and
sporting beasts if you enjoyed this
video check out our other awesome videos
on the channel thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time
[Music]